sleep
ing
[Music]
Moody Corridor cast intro welcome back
to the corridor digital podcast
everybody episode
153 Sam got the last episode number
wrong it's okay we corrected it with
text on screen text I saw that's what we
did
for putting our pictures on screen for
the last one so if we do pictures in the
future we'll make sure they end up on
screen
yeah yes yeah well that was a fun one
I'm glad you guys did that um wow did
you guys nerd out hard yeah it was great
it was great it was exhausting yeah
it's not about AI
yeah yeah anyways
this episode is about son of a dungeon
everybody yeah
yeah congratulations on having 155
podcast episodes guys thanks oh yeah I I
think this is 153 Carmichael so
congratulations on having over 150
episodes that's pretty sweet yeah we're
still uh honing in on what the hell this
thing is but um it's getting there you
know little by little it doesn't need to
be more than it is yeah no I have
thought about changing the name of it to
something more apt to like the relevance
of the topics of the show you know
or digital is maybe they would be more
interested in like Hunter Street a named
podcast you know
but uh yeah son of a dungeon
yeah that was that was an exciting drop
yeah wait what's the timeline in this
podcast right now
two days ago this is being recorded 48
hours before
48 hours after yep that's just how it
how it goes but I mean you know spoilers
spoilers are okay to say yeah because
we're not spoiling anything anymore you
go dies Nico died I do actually die wait
we shouldn't spoil things I'm sure not
everyone's watched son of a dungeon
within two days oh well we just spoiled
me now
well do I actually Tire am I just
pulling your leg
yeah so somehow is that a joke
you're just we're just scrambling the
cover of tracks um
yeah it's tough I yeah it's hard doing a
podcast right now because it's like it's
I'm getting like Whiplash yeah
everything's going on like trying to
actually export this stuff episode one
and two are exporting right now that's
great news yeah
sweet and then I'm going to send it over
to Jake for closed captions yeah it's so
hard
so hard guys so much content it's like
the crazy thing about this dang show is
that it's like
it's like how I want to find what the
like what's the hour like multiplier oh
yeah for every hour we played DND how
many freaking hours can we put into it
uh since then like it's just so crazy uh
you know because
we started this whole thing off going
you know what guys let's make a we want
to make a low impact show so let's play
D D
let's call Carmichael we end up still
with like a full like TV season's length
of footage that then we just can't help
but go well let's treat it all like it's
like the highest quality stuff and
everything has to be amazing so let's do
all these renders and sound design and
so you're still applying it to that many
minutes of footage it just happens to be
that the footage itself is just a guy
sitting around the table instead of like
doing flips driving cars shooting doing
shooting guns like it's just right
they're just sitting there rolling dice
we're sitting there rolling dice we have
to sound design the crap out of it the
photography is a lot for people who
don't know what you're saying like
basically what that means is the
photography is way easier on set on the
day it's less days yeah to capture that
many minutes and we thought that that
would be an advantage but what ended up
happening is even though the photography
was easier the entirety of
post-production has been just as much
work as any other show that is nine
hours long yep yeah
so and then splitting that up between
like you know six people basically yeah
thank God yeah
anyways remember when it was it's cool
what remember when it was just us season
one yeah
since then we've we have four more
people that have been helping basically
yeah which does help oh my God it's the
constant thing of like you get it's it's
what you know everyone's talking about
you know uh we we have recently had Tim
Miller for VFX artist react Yeah Tim
Miller was in this morning uh John I
think Jerome
but they're from blur Studios and like
uh you know
we can relate which is
you talk about rendering time you talk
about rendering speed like oh this is
slow render and then when you get your
new GPU or your new CPU and you're like
sweet my renders will take less time
and then you just make them crazier yeah
yeah and then they take just as long and
so that's the kind of the effect it's
like great we have more editors great
we've got more if VFX help now and we
have a team and then we're like cool so
that means we can do more shots so we
just do more shots
well I feel like now we have more shots
but the product is better the product
the product is better it's so much
better it's so so so so one more so much
better I do think we learned where our
cap was on the green screen photography
though
because in season one we're like okay
we gotta bring all this all these shots
down to like 20 a day
and we barely got by but we're like okay
20 you know we were pretty consistent we
got out and a good time every day this
season we're like we're gonna aim for
30.
well like and then we struggled we
genuinely struggled to get 30. our
setups evolved too this year but the
green screen shots they're the they're
the chocolate fudge on your Sunday right
like you're that's the whole reason I
mean that's ice cream it's also the
number yeah
it's also the number one thing about son
of a dungeon compared to any of the
other d d shows out there right it is
the green screen photography and the
Unreal Engine all combined into one yeah
I mean the there's a million things to
talk about like obviously like just the
Unreal Engine renders that aren't green
screen like have a whole new life the
Universe last season but the green
screen itself you know it's like
you get the actors together you have the
costumes you do the shoot on the green
screen but having done that what's what
did you guys learn from this year what
did you get to do this year that you
couldn't do from season one like what
what was the yeah I guess actual track
camera
it's like suggestion of a track yeah we
we did a lot less Scooby-Doo shots
and what that what that is is we would
have everyone pretend they're walking
and then we would just move the
background we did that quite a bit in
season one
it looks funny but it also kind of works
but then but then in this season we did
like one and then I don't even think we
tossed it into the edit yeah I mean yeah
we have a real green screen for this
year's so yeah dungeon the first son of
a dungeon was shot in the cloth green
screen or paper green paper green screen
papers here's my season three pitch I'm
already doing it uh-oh let's still do
Eight Episodes yeah let's make them 30
minutes long okay
we will be far less I think I think
because like I'm starting to see it with
the season
like the editing style is like even more
distilled to the point where like dice
rolls and like the rules and stuff are
like they're not they're not like speed
bumps like they were in the first season
right now they're they're just like
they're just like just just a little bit
of you know just they go by and it's
perfect it's like super smooth narrative
editing I love how you guys are doing
dice rolls in the season I've always
hated dice rolls and d d games I love
what they imply I love when they happen
because it's like they're you're at a
story Branch yeah something's going to
happen that no one can control meaning
like this story is not being contrived
it's going to play out naturally and
you'll have to react to it it's just fun
that's what I like about it but in every
other D show like I just don't really
like how they've done the dice rolls but
the way you guys approached it I really
like that well normally the audience is
left out like the closest people that
I've ever seen get like do something
what we do is uh
college humor is where they have like a
little dice cam box so that way the
audience can be in on the excitement for
the role which is the whole point of it
right it's a slot machine it's slot
machine
so yeah we made a slot machine yeah okay
it helps a lot it helps a lot
I mean I remember reviewing the first
five minutes of episode one
and I was like okay sound music the
effects is all in it okay let's see this
and then Christian's watching over my
shoulder and the first thing he goes we
got dice rolls
no it's nice it's super nice
um yeah like I think that element is
like it's really good like right now
it's like so distilled though story like
we have that special sequence in the
fourth episode
where we are sticking to like we have
yes I'm glad we did that because
watching it like we I even had them they
re-rendered it like again yes now
because like I noticed like the sync was
off but we managed to like do yeah seven
to eight minutes or so it's just like
basically all on the green screen it was
such a commitment on the day on the
green screen we're like do we just roll
for the next 10 minutes straight it was
something it wasn't hard for any of the
actors no no it was so easy we in fact I
think it was the most effective use of
this whole system so far because it was
the first time where we're like cool
we're not like doing complex blocking or
takes or anything we're like literally
just sinking us it's we're just shooting
to the game for for people who don't
know what Sam's talking about right now
we did a shot where there are multiple
characters talking
as they are speaking in the edit but
there's a Drunk History it's Drunk
History
yeah which was the original
conceptualization of the show
at least I thought so that's how I was
pitching it to myself anyway and so it's
really fun to be able to do that in this
season which it happens in episode four
yeah I think the reality of actually
doing the Drunk History thing is not
nearly as compelling or effective as one
would think uh if we were to do it for
everything it'd be really like yeah but
utilizing it in season three as another
camera angle
uh and adding it to now the the animated
minis which we have now the regular
green screenshots the table shots the
top down shots
using it using it like that might be
interesting yeah I
I like the use of it for
dialogue scenes that need to be there
and it's going to be hey you guys are
sitting there talking for 10 minutes
it's important yeah
um and I remember the first time it went
on to the edit we were like all in
character for most of that junk like
because that's the other things like
most of the time we're playing it's like
we're all over the place you know right
you guys were actually in it and you
guys were having a conversation
um well there's like a lot so much
action you know what I'm saying yeah
it's hard because it's like so we'll go
there and say a few things but like
we're going to leave this room in a few
minutes because we're like looking for
something or we're trying to accomplish
something and so it's hard to it's it's
hard to slot that in in most places
right and I like the fact that we
dedicated a nice big chunk of VFX to
dialogue role play yeah
um and what was fun was when it was
first put in it was just a blanket over
the whole bit
and it was also the beginning of the
episode and I just found myself so
Jarred that I was like who's talking
right now and then I started chopping it
up and it's not really spoilers I'm
chopping it up and uh
I found it really compelling match
cutting
between who's speaking at the table to
them speaking
as character on the green screen just
like a few times just to like this is
what we're doing and then we stay in it
cool it was really satisfying
that's cool I can't wait to see it yeah
it's sweet so season three
minutes Sam you think we can make the
same we can do the same amount of table
play and cut that down to 30 minutes so
that that's where this is where my I
will you're you're crazy man I think if
you want shorter episodes that's shorter
the the work goes at the table that's
shorter game plays
and I don't and I don't think that's a
the best move we could definitely
shorten the gameplays rather than two
and a half hours we clock it at two no
more than that but I do think
half the amount of episodes like we can
play for Eight Episodes got it no
problem but then we focus on like half
season releases so we're not spending 12
months on Eight Episodes we're spending
six months on four done then six months
on four that's my thinking for season
three yeah well
we'll get there
we'll get there I don't know if there's
any advantage to that or not it's it's
hard to tell what are uh um what are
some of the other things that you guys
have like really felt the leap in from
season one to season two Fenner
Cece Cece Center
yeah the rock lift effect uh yeah yeah
a little bit of the uh like the Allen
special like floating around the corner
yes yeah yeah Jordan Allen special is
always welcome
Griffin's art yeah his character art and
then uh using his character art more
often so like if you guys are in a
dialogue scene with a few NPCs I'm like
tossing them up more Yep so that way we
know who's talking I know rest in peace
Griffin Griffin in his art obviously
next year we'll be replacing him with
the uh the AI obviously
I will print the AI on Griffin's art wow
wow yeah we have embedded Griffin into
our infrastructure he'll become his uh
eventually his nerves will mesh with the
ethernet cables uh it'll give him more
time for thumbnails let's be honest
yeah you'll need a big like Red Bull
like that's actually you know Luke
Skywalker style and Empire Strikes Back
and he's like I got all the wires like
going into him yeah that's actually an
interesting idea when when can it when
can the AI here it is
on doing thumbnails in a specific Style
so VFX artist react thumbnails are done
it doesn't matter it it doesn't YouTube
thumbnail in the style of griffinthorne
it doesn't it doesn't matter because at
the end of the day the good like a good
thumbnail needs the time put into the
concept yeah in this story in the idea
and the actual video itself has to mesh
with that as well so it's like
like there's definitely craft and skill
and Artistry and making it eye-catching
but the best like that's only a a
fraction of the total job yeah and an AI
can't do the total job you heard it here
Griffin your job is safe yeah no I don't
think no yeah yeah
so basically uh wait until you guys find
out about the next thing that happened
in the past two weeks in AI
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
stop it oh no so yeah I really want to
play DND we should make uh we should do
like a one shot game for fun this this
winter yeah another Christmas themed
game
Christmas themed games are wonderful
yeah just uh Ricky Ray keeps asking too
we wanted we want to really bring in the
X car The X Factor The X Factor for sure
no
no I don't know he's gonna ask you crazy
[Laughter]
I'll get him fired if I describe
what he did in those games
I remember Denny specifically say hey I
I work for Bill Gates no you can't tell
anyone
I can't tell anyone I don't think you
said any of that no I remember he
mentioned like please don't talk about
it publicly you can't talk publicly
about what I did in those d d games
uh yeah oh man
oh gosh yeah yeah it's been another
journey I didn't think that this season
was going to take us a year
um and somehow here we are in September
once again yeah drop another season yeah
technically that's not a year but we did
technically start shooting it in what
February January February so it was
filmed it in February yep
yeah yeah some solid r d happens between
Seasons but yeah the the brainstorming
of the Season before filming started
like at Christmas well yeah that's what
I'm saying you kind of got to take that
into account like you have to take into
account the really production the the
the the the the combination and writing
so to speak yeah brain you know and like
the resetting
then the gearing up the brainstorming
all of that is part of the process I
think yeah all the all the after hour
texts yeah
because if you tried to slam the five
months between season one and when we
filmed season two
into
less time than that I don't know it
wouldn't it wouldn't have come out the
way that it did yeah well okay so here's
the Big Challenge the challenge is
making into a show like that's the
that's the pressure which is like when I
playing a d d game for fun is there's
pressure because you know there's
pressure to like
entertain and to like make sure that
like yeah a few things feel cohesive so
that way you're people playing the game
don't have like a you don't want to make
it feel random or like yeah you don't
like the effect of the single player d d
thing where where it's just like dude
you're just making [ __ ] you know
what I mean like you're just saying the
opposite of whatever I want to do you
know like because that that effect
that's the worst but like when it's a
show where you're like oh shoot like
this needs to be a cool story that has
like makes sense those moments and has
like some level of like emotion or drama
of you know what if a series or of
narrative is supposed to have that's
that's like this difficult part to do
and I mean I think we did it a little
bit better but it's like it's still one
of those things where I watch it now and
I'm like [ __ ] it would have been so much
cooler to do this they're like this or
that but it's just like even in the
moment there's like no control over yeah
that just means you're becoming a better
some of that stuff yeah yeah just means
you're improving but there's definitely
I think more of that like we had a
couple of those beats in the first
season but like this one is like a
little bit more consistent with twists
and turns and like emotional like drama
yeah yeah stuff you know like after this
podcast or is that podcast after the
season finishes a son of a dungeon two
we should talk about the power outage
branch that could have been yeah yeah we
can't talk about it any more than that
now that's all we're gonna say but let's
just say there's a power outage and we
went down a branch in the story
that was amazing
and it is just for us it was just for us
around the table because the power
outage happened and that was all that's
left is our memories yep that makes me
very very sad
but but truly if it was just a d d game
and it wasn't being recorded
it still would have been that would have
kept going it was just for us you know
yeah that's why we need those battery
walls though well I got three batteries
on every camera now yep
that's a good idea yeah
because
yeah so that was the most stressful
thing in the world yeah
[Applause]
we're right in the middle it was gay
it was six or seven uh it was day
it was episode I'm not gonna say what up
okay I'm not even gonna say what day
yeah after it was late it was late after
afterward when The Season's done no and
this is too easy I'm just talking about
what happened I'm not talking about the
game okay and the power goes out
everything just
and we have like servers on we've got
fans on there's cameras on there's fans
everywhere just going yeah and then just
silence and you can immediately feel the
heat of the air conditioners go out and
we know already before we even checked
that we lost all the footage
you hear the the back door slide open
you just hear me running out
turn the cameras off or whatever you
yeah what were you saying I'm so scared
yeah so we lost some footage but
whatever you know we lost some of the
professionals yeah
we didn't lose three hours of footage
it's not like the series is scripted by
any means
one scene had to be redone uh yeah but
yeah very stressful
yeah so I will I will here's the thing
here's the thing look we gotta stop
talking about it but I'm just gonna say
it's one thing oh okay
I want to talk about it a little bit too
what was lost
wasn't just a scene it was something
special
something very special but it is very
much
replaced by something else that's also
very special yeah but
the morale in our hearts to continue
going yeah oh God that's so funny
thinking about that yeah I don't even
know
you talk about it we'll have to we'll
revisit this topic I I have about it 80
the accuracy of knowing what would have
how that day would have ended oh my God
man
oh man oh man it's so funny I know yeah
okay I'll just quietly chuckling to
ourselves like all right all right so
but we can't talk through it so season
three are we are we gonna season three
let's talk about season two is it gonna
take one more season to finish this
campaign though yes yes and it's awesome
it's really amazing like all the fun
things that were in the first two
seasons like so the second season I
personally think the second season is
like probably about 20 times better than
the first season yeah um mostly possible
for getting that automatically for no
but forgetting like the VFX and crap
like it's it's it's more entertaining to
watch like it's a better story
everyone's really on the game and like
everyone's being really creative
um so it's just it's that much better
um but yeah it definitely is the thing
where you when you finish the second
season
there's just like this like oh man like
dude just we get there's it we're
totally not done like it's there's that
one last block that completes basically
everything yeah and all the characters
can die at the end of the third season
and it would be fine yeah you know yeah
we're also starting to approach that
power level right it's like you passed
that we were just we're just yeah kind
of at the end of this season let's see
which is like we basically we're doing
like leveling up one level per like play
session which is definitely like speed
leveling yes so within that first season
everyone was starting around like level
four or something like that and so this
season people start around like level
eight or nine and so by the end of the
season if you you know do the math
people are pretty uh pretty powered up
you know yeah and most games end at
level 10. yeah yeah so like if we do a
third season we have this really unique
situation too where it's like almost
demigods yeah
only you get to do what only one percent
of d d players ever get to do yeah by
the end of season three we will be
commanding the forces of nature well
we're already commanding the forces of
nature yeah but you were commanding the
force of nature in the first episode too
special thing about like this story
right now is that like it's a like
long-running DND campaigns in my opinion
have they I mean just like any other
show or narrative watching like there's
this huge amount of of like weight to
them where like okay we've been in these
different situations there's all these
characters all these events and
experiences like
there's a lot of stuff there and to
capitalize it on it for like the idea of
like creating a conclusion is like has
meaning now you know it's not like the
one shot like Hey we're all gonna like
this is just like hey a fun little game
we're goofing around but now it's like
okay everyone kind of feels like okay we
got a little bit of stakes here for
these characters or like you've got a
minute or there's these these ideas of
things that the care you guys want to
accomplish yeah in this in this story so
to speak and so that's why it's like so
juicy and we're finally like
like the second season is where we start
that stuff where it like starts to
happen and
yeah so
I was thinking about it this morning I
was like right I was like I gotta start
writing this stuff or like I mean
writing a script for all the lines yeah
yeah because we have to plan all our
numbers for like the dice rolls and
stuff yeah yeah
each dice rolls a specific numbers
do we actually want in season three yeah
this is like the WWE version of of
Dungeons and Dragons
the WWE version of d d
I mean it's not that far off actually
now I start to think about it
one's just a little more improv theater
than the other but yeah they have like
they have a good cross section well they
decide what they decide what the roles
are that's true yeah I mean that's more
like the whole point of us
that's the DND where you sit down and
say all right everyone
here's what we're trying to get out of
this scene
handle that but you know we're all
working towards the same thing right you
know right so yeah there's a scene where
Nico's gonna die here at the end we
really want to make it seem like no one
saw it coming yeah okay you guys all
ready for that moment yeah okay yeah you
guys will make it dramatic though right
not too sad like somebody's got a
one-liner too okay cool yeah yeah yeah
you got a good one-liner okay all right
I mean you could totally do that you're
you're going to waterboard right a lot
of DnD shows probably do do that
I should also go further that the ending
credit scene of episode one is this joke
yes
no yeah no yeah it's 100 raw actual d d
i mean people have seen on node videos
it's like it's legit yeah pretty legit
but that's why it's so cool like it's
it's it's my favorite medium personally
because you know you it's fun you know
you I love you know coming up and
brainstorming I it's it's the same
process with videos where like for me
the brainstorming part is awesome
because you're there all right we're
collaborating figuring things out it's
like super exciting and then when it
comes to write it you're just like
you force yourself to sit down and type
each letter and you're like oh it's so
painful to like actually like commit
things yep to like text but you know
that d d is 100 that brainstorming
process you're like literally
brainstorming every second you're
playing it well so I had
um yesterday was just like what one of
the reasons I really love DND as a
medium is like
it's the same reason why you love
filmmaking it it's a collaborative
process that you have an intended output
but because everyone is contributing
their own creativity something slightly
new and different sort of pop out and
that's kind of the beauty of filmmaking
it's like yeah well it's also it's in
this imagine you're in a brainstorming
session yeah and people are like saying
what's the best thing for this guy to do
in this situation and everyone's got a
different idea yeah but the thing is is
that not everything's gonna stick
because ultimately you're trying to
settle on like the best version of
something right whereas in D and D it's
like okay it could be the worst if
you're imagine a brainstorming session
where each time someone says an idea
they have to roll like it locks into
place and you're like oh [ __ ] like like
you just said that you wanted to like do
this flip over there but then this thing
blows up or whatever and you're like oh
CR dude God dang it like yeah it's like
now we have to do this the story all
right I always wonder if you know Batman
vs Superman movie if they actually
brought the the actors in to play Batman
vs Superman D and D for a Sunday and
that's how they would get the draft and
I was like that would be probably the
greatest Batman versus Superman movie
that's really funny yeah I mean it's a
really great way of like because that's
that's the funny thing though is that
with with that process though it still
gives you that
really dynamic
story that you want to see it's great
yeah it's yeah it's almost like you're
you're you're reacting the whole time
rather than yes then you know a more
like affirmative action taking process
agreed
yeah
I've never thought about it like that
but that's totally true well some of
my favorite thing in d d is is also in
the second season it's like it was the
it was like the first time where like I
feel like everyone started like kind of
like
well there's like there's this constant
element of distrust you know
or it's like okay first season well in
all seasons it's like actually in the
first season dude I'm sitting back here
watching you guys just distrust Sam's
like guys we have eight more days of
shooting like just keep going I know the
first episode of the first season is
like there's a cave and everyone's like
I don't know
should we go in there and it's like uh I
don't know it's like guys come on
just just go in there I'm not gonna kill
you
back quick
we should do a campaign where that where
you try to kill us in the first episode
though
whatever it could be season three who
knows oh my God that's so funny yeah I
mean but that's the thing with this one
I felt that was like everyone was a much
more comfortable just like just doing
something and not like going oh God am I
like am I gonna die around that corner
every single second yeah corner I mean
like that's why it's much that's why it
flows better is because there's way less
there's way less uh like speculation
about stuff like that you know what I'm
saying it's like cool like there's a
room like hey let's go there all right
I'm opening the door we're going in like
we're doing it and it's like it it like
flows because of that
um yeah what do you get what do you
normally do to these guys
unlike DND games that they don't trust
you on the first door of the first I
don't know minute no that's part of the
fun if the if the dungeon master is not
your adversary then like
as the DM I play Both Sides right of
course I mean but if the dungeon
Master's your friend they're gonna make
sure you have a good time right you know
they're different in real life yeah I
found this out over the uh the other
company
they're just trying to make you they're
just trying to make your games
isn't that a thing isn't that like the
Pathfinder Society
effectively that competitive D it's like
yeah the Pathfinder Society is this
thing where it's I think you have to be
like I don't know if you need like a
certificate to become a DM or something
like that but it's like it's very very
like well it's it's very strict you know
there's like there's not like there's
the idea is that there's like zero like
rule wiggle room so to speak and you can
go to these games that are like there's
no home brewery there's no ruling it's
just rules yeah and I mean I mean I feel
like that's kind of interesting so that
way like anyone can just hop in and like
be a part of a story but at the same
time time it's like I wonder
I don't know have you ever been to a
convention and played d d at a
convention never okay so there's an
interview with a DM from one of those
conventions each game is 60 Minutes long
that's great well
um wow his job is to get your attention
move get through the story and stuff if
you as the group who've paid to sit at
this table to play D D whoa you pay you
pay you're crazy
Dungeons and Dragons tournament and now
if you if you go to the DM go hey man
we're just gonna play we're gonna have
some laughs you're probably just gonna
get about a quarter way through but
he'll chill off and be a little bit more
relaxed but he was talking about how I
have to get through this entire module
in 60 minutes
it doesn't matter how you join the
campaign he's like talking about all
these different shortcuts and thinking
processes
um I watched that interview not just
because I'm obsessed with d d but uh as
as a DM on the weekends A friend of mine
has Ms and she only has four hours a day
to play D D otherwise her brain just
starts taking her down for the rest of
the day so time management in my mind
when I play D D is super important
uh wait are you saying she only has four
hours a day to like be active and alert
or she only has four hours a day to play
D and D
to be active and alert um
quite a long time every you add up every
day yeah okay but she like but even even
those four hours she has a migraine
every Sunday right so like I have to
like
I'm I actively try to make sure it's
under four hours to get to either the
hook or and that's the end
all right so I'm reading a bit up on
competitive D and yeah you do that
here's here's a couple tidbits
apparently uh there's a few things
um there's a d d Sports a new online d d
tournament a tournament is built as a
way for competitive games to get
comfortable with trying dunsonite
dragons as well as unique way to
distinct the versatility of dnd's fifth
edition combat system the games are
relatively simple
so this is just one version of
competitive D I gotta saying Dungeons
and Dragons is a sport is like saying
gambling is a sport
I'm a professional sports asset what
sport do you play I'm a gambling I'm a
gambling athlete all right two teams of
four characters will be placed in a
dungeon and will battle to the death
players will choose from a collection of
15 pre-generated characters each with
their own unique abilities and traits oh
wow so you can't pick your own character
you just I mean okay so that that makes
sense but here's a big question what
level are they do they know because
that's a lot of stuff you gotta memory
generated so I mean oh yeah here's a
level 11 fighter hope you know all the
ways to use that that's this is just one
version of competitive DND though let's
see yeah we're talking about competitive
D competitive PVP DND yeah yeah gosh
DDT RPG I have to admit though out of
all the d d shows that I watch
the the most boring part of it is combat
I agree I have to I have to watch combat
at almost two times speed just to enjoy
myself combat and d d moves slow anyways
it does it's it's not our combat our
combat moves slow also it does think of
how fast like the game literally takes
it's they say it right there in front of
you six seconds of game time for your
turn in real life so you really slow the
world down to sit like a second for
every minute that you're like talking
working you know yeah yeah yeah and also
everyone just starts there's a few
outliers of players out there that do a
really good job at bringing role play
and just flourishing the narration of
how they do something cool
but that's an outlier most of the time
players DM they're like math
yeah you get to okay hit yep you yeah it
hits you okay cool and it's just like it
becomes less interesting yeah yes it hit
you I try to hit him and you hit him
guys I want to go inside the world and
do a documentary following around a
professional DND competitive D player
around the globe
like
think about that gosh that's funny it's
a I wonder if there's a dark gritty
version of that world that we don't know
they must have like weight classes or
like wait like level tens you know right
yeah you're level 10. yeah but that's
that's cool
for years and got like some rare
treasure and then the other guy didn't
and they're both level 10. but that's
that's actually a thing from past D and
D is like oh my DM gave me this giant
Frost sword from the giant keep yeah
it's impossible to do oh okay I guess
that's okay no there has to be items
that were in the books and stuff so
that's how 5e now works I know but what
if I was just like guys guys I'm rigging
the match so level one you find this
chest that has 20 like wondrous rare
items in it don't tell anyone I gave it
to you
they only unlock if you happen to play
competitively
kid I'm giving you a lemon secret chest
with items in it that can only be
unlocked during a competitive tournament
and then there's this one player that
you really don't like you just give him
a mimic yeah
I like how someone finally caught in the
comments that it takes up one minute to
cast uh Lehman's tiny Hut
doesn't it it's one is it one minute no
it's ten minutes it costs 10 minutes is
it okay yeah it's a it's a time it's a
substantial yeah it's not a battle spell
but yeah too late
that's that's almost like 200 rounds of
combat yeah well we bring that up and
they'll get in eight seconds it's the
second season it becomes that
role-playing storyline element yeah it's
so funny it's like
instantly top of the episode okay we're
gonna fight
force field
impenetrable eight-hour long force field
God damn
and you got around it though you got
around it yeah there was a moment where
it's like oh we're all screwed we're
gonna die yep yeah yeah and then then
you did
I die later later in the episode yeah or
did I or are we just being sarcastic so
I've mentioned the story I'm not sure if
I mentioned on a podcast if you're
watching live go ahead uh there's a
story about being told spoilers right
this is the spoilers here it's like it's
about spoilers oh sure I think if you
want your friend to really enjoy a piece
of media
accidentally quote-unquote spoil it
telling that one of the main characters
die yeah so like anytime that you get to
like like oh they're hanging off the car
oh the bombs counting down like that's
like the person be like wait is this are
they actually gonna die and it'll make
the experience so much more intensive
yeah because you're looking for it
you're looking for it yeah but what if
they don't and then they watch the whole
thing and they're like what the hell man
yeah yeah so that's what happened it
makes the viewing experience great but
then it makes the end suck you just feel
like I don't know yeah I didn't say they
died that's like watching Mulholland
Drive over and over again looking for a
conclusion that never happens yeah I
mean yeah maybe you could do that or
maybe not don't do that too I mean I
still to this day despise that movie and
I know that it's David Lynch movie dude
my buddy wanted to watch it in high
school you remember Raleigh shettka yeah
of course you remember that guy yeah he
was kind of a quirky dude and he was
like yo we're gonna watch we're all
gonna get together and we're gonna watch
Mulholland Drive it's the best movie
ever and I was like so stoked I was like
okay cool Riley's got this movie where
we went and rented it because that's
when you did that sort of thing
we had a we rented it from like
Blockbuster wherever yeah but who who
went to Blockbuster to get it but he's
probably just because he was in high
school and there's nudity in it but I
was waiting for like a conclusion I was
waiting for a plot the entire time and
it was like okay what there's no plot I
don't know how they did it I think
that's one of his worst movies they did
90 minutes one not a not a single plot
there's this that that's the movie with
the witch on the scooter right or The
Witcher stuff that happens is it just a
Vibe movie or just you Vibe yeah it's
like a Vibe movie yeah
well there you have it so anyway that's
my gripe I still 20 years later I'm
still griping about
the three water Lots get stuck in
Mulholland Drive
no conclusion season three son of a
dungeon will just be us vibing in like a
Tavern Just Vibe so don't do that
episode was just in the tavern another
there's nothing it's just mini games
just Tavern games
Warren Warren watt is playing as a
dungeon master dice playing in Dungeons
and Dragons with everyone else at the
table and you're playing nice to see
what number your dice gets yeah
the DM is playing an NPC who's actually
a player I really I mean I still think
the Renaissance Fair one shot game would
be [ __ ] great it's just people go to
the Renaissance Fair
obviously it's like the heightened
version where there's drama and maybe
there's like a murder mystery happening
but it's like it's just the Renaissance
wait can we do that could we go to the
ren fair with with dice and then one of
us is a dungeon master and you have to
make sure it makes you roll to do
different things that you want to do at
the at the ren fair and it's like you go
ax throwing and you don't actually hit
the axes you just I want to drink eight
medes and you're like okay you're gonna
have to roll for that sure I mean maybe
uh all the all the patrons there are
just like super confused like you walk
up
everybody at the Renaissance Fair would
be very annoyed with you because they
all know exactly what you're doing
you're like no this is not a joke this
is for serious medieval reenactments
most certainly a joke it's not a game
no smiling you need one person who is I
mean that's like a table
[Laughter]
that's pretty good that's incredible uh
but no when I worked at the Renaissance
Festival yeah everyone was super serious
about like no this is a reaction of us
of this window of time and what is that
window of time tell me it's like an 800
years the 800 year period so I would
argue it's somewhere like 1500 to 15
50-ish I was gonna say 14 to uh 16. yeah
but you can also go dress like an 11th
century Knight dude
perfect time for me to [ __ ] gripe
about all the people who go to the
Renaissance Fair is like steampunk [ __ ]
or Doctor Who oh God it's like very
clever very clever let's like oh like
going to Disney World as like uh like a
like you know uh I don't know some
freaking other franchise that's not
Disney yeah it's like oh yeah
yeah oh you yeah you go to Disneyland as
a minion and it's like and everyone's
like you expect people to like
congratulate you on how witty you are
you know you're like wow that's clever
that's I did not see a minion here
because I did not realize that would
work you know to be fair the first time
you see Doctor Who at a ren Fair your
brain goes ha ha you're like very clever
yes I mean I know maybe the dog the
Doctor Who is like okay like sure time
travel okay but steampunk or get out or
medieval Batman or medieval uh Wolverine
yeah no
[Music]
look Marvel and DC have become so
corporate yeah that like it's like were
they not they weren't no the 90s
when it was just a scrappy cheaply
printed comic there was some charm and
then but then the 90s cartoons I don't
know cartoons no whatever I'm not gonna
Weighing on that too much I'm just
saying I'm gonna leave that one on the
table I'm just saying steampunk people
on the costume table
yeah I mean that wasn't even a time you
know even in time travel fantasy that's
just fantasy of a the wrong time period
yeah like Western 1800s fantasy
yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't make any
sense no it does not make sense
as an anime yeah no anime people you can
go as Western uh Western Marty McFly
maybe maybe Western Marty McFly I know
but you're really close because now you
need a train
yeah like I didn't want this experience
I wanna I just want some dusty people
with tunics and stuff
doesn't need to go experience nights if
you want to be an anime person or go to
anime yeah go to Anime Expo dress up and
go there
Marty McFly you know wearing like uh
like a popper or like a little you know
funny hat or something like he tried
hold traveled in time back then like my
reaction would be the same as someone of
the time or I would try and burn them
you know which like I have the same
sensation like you do not belong here
[Applause]
in one this situation you're breaking
the reality of someone else and this one
you're breaking my illusion you know
and it's like it's very yeah it's very
bad to do that but you're also watching
the
night events at Ren fairs if the ren
fair is supposed to happen in the
Renaissance which is you know the from
about 1450 onward then the night battles
are like 200 years prior to that
especially with a lot of the way that
they dress unless they're in the full
shining like silver medal where every
piece is covered and it's that really
light armor that was like mid 1400s well
maybe Jake maybe do you think we have
Recreations of like cowboy duels maybe
we're actually seeing they were doing
creation no no see what the Renaissance
Fair it's a perfect Recreation of that
time in the Renaissance perfect when
they had fares where they did historical
Recreations of jousting from 200 years
be prior to the historical Recreations
of jousting from 200 years ago did they
that's what they're going to say about
it I'm probably actually I don't you
know they just do jousting with the
tools that they had I don't think
jousting ever has gone out of style
there's probably there's probably been
at least one yeah
Justin kind of came in in the 11th
century and it's been popular since then
yeah
I find it just anywhere
somewhere yeah they kept the tradition
alive okay so yeah like I think yeah the
Jousting is like a little bit definitely
just a little bit earlier but once again
think about like the if it's a
Renaissance Fair too by the way you know
it's what if it's like an early
Renaissance Fair like
it's like right and it's no I mean it's
just saying it's like right when that
Renaissance is kicking off yeah it's the
Renaissance but a lot of society still
hasn't like kind of conformed you know
we're like it's it's still in early
adoption stages the Dark Age so that way
like you still get your Jazz thing you
still have all your you know Sports
we're on the cusp of the Enlightenment
we're on the cusp of the Enlightenment
Enlightenment but not quite yet so you
still have this beautiful blending of
Two Worlds um no Dynamic vibrant time if
I was Doctor Who I would definitely go
to that point
like if I could travel in time to any
point in time it'd be then
get an uncurable cold
I'm curable cold
yeah
give them an uncurable cold
the 2020 cold I would if I would bring
covet back to those times
[Laughter]
those are just like easy shocking jokes
to say because then it would have been
around for 500 years by the time that we
you know we got it
so yeah we've we've helped prevent it
we'd be like oh it's fine
true very true oh that's funny yeah I
don't know I I do respect all the work
that goes into those costumes though I
mean oh it's very beautiful the the guys
who are actually doing you know some of
the the bludgeoning and the battles with
the swords and stuff I mean are they
gonna talk about like the gears and the
top hat and the goggles that you put
yeah
yeah like gluing all that
all those gears to your hat it takes so
freaking long
now we had an opportunity that we were
going to do this yesterday
if you're listening and you like
steampunk you know steampunk's cool man
that's fine I'm just we're talking about
leave the house okay the wrong
you know there's a right place and a
right time for everything that's all I'm
gonna say there's at least one person we
know who's probably into steampunk stuff
and wears steampunk stuff to the
Renaissance Festival and they're just
like oh damn man damn guys come on start
a steampunk Festival like go to a boiler
room
yeah invite everyone down there
hey guys I found a sick boiler room here
like it's actual
actual water heater it's like actually
making steam
what a low blow
no but I mean there are places like that
you guys have been to that remember that
one place uh in downtown yeah the
something nickel or something like that
yeah
what's a gal there's something nickel I
forget what it's called yeah whatever
that was the most steampunky place I've
ever been yeah you go there with the hat
you could go there yeah
and it's it's really cool it's very
high-end it doesn't feel cheap you know
of places you can go with that hat in
the comments or in the description of
the video yeah
hey guys I have this top hat with gears
that took a long time for me to get into
this
appropriately what place is
[Laughter]
yeah yeah we're gonna do artificers and
[ __ ] like that like little Dwarfs with
gears
they build like
glasses
you did make us get a gear in episode
one and I was thinking it was going that
way for a second no no no I did not for
a lift yeah it's like an actual fun the
idea is there was a functional like gear
yeah kind of situation gosh
oh man
if you haven't watched episode one and
two uh definitely go check them out and
then um we're gonna be dropping episodes
weekly starting on Wednesday two days
from now yeah on the 21st if I have my
no do I have my dates right
no oh my God you keep changing I'm so
bad at this I told somebody 20th you
corrected me and said 21st 21st 21st I
had my calendar on the wrong month on
the 21st episode 3 is going to drop then
they're gonna be weekly all the way to
November
or full week Edison that's the place
it's called The Edison yes yeah right
that's right that's what it was that's
where you can go it is called the Edison
it is appropriate the Edison's on
quarter digital.com what
sorry tangents no son of dungeons on
quarter digital.com wait from season one
to season two
green screen was built aperture lighting
like came out with new lights and we
hooked them up and shot the whole thing
wait till you see the lighting that I
have planned for season three we shot at
new cameras we have we had a PTZ camera
a remote control camera for one another
game board shots we had new sound
systems
we had a bunch of costumes we had new 3D
printed minis I believe we had to do
costumes we had new props we had a table
tracking system we had a whole new table
uh like the first season yeah
um on your engine five versus Unreal
Engine four we got a donkey we got
donkey uh multiple new editors
um yeah just the insane amount they just
expanded everything and
all of that is only possible because of
people subscribing on the website that's
what we get to do when we have actual
direct relationship with our audience
and like we don't have to go through a
Netflix to make a show or a Hulu or
anything like that that's the promise of
a low impact show
definitely a low impact show it's a it's
an awesome show but I'm just like when I
think about that like the fact that we
got to add all of that to this because
of people's support and making it it's
wonderful pretty wacky stuff in a cool
way yeah it's super sweet it's super
super sweet I personally am really
appreciative of all the subscribers on
the website because I no longer get paid
through the AdSense
yeah there you go I mean it's true it's
like you know we there's actual
subscribers and they actually support us
I still remember the blast it sucks that
this is coming out after we're not
actually getting to experience this yet
but it's like the explosion of the
website when the first episode dropped
that like the website crashed all right
and every and like just so many people
flooded in oh we should make sure
Scott's Ready
YouTube Premiere ends on episode one
there is the biggest Spike of traffic
yeah the website so question I want I
want to confirm this because I I think I
know the answer
the plan is
episode one the same time on website in
YouTube
it's a live chat
I believe so right yep but that will
yeah
I know I'm fully I'm bringing them into
this conversation guys that's why I'm
doing it now yeah uh and then the plan
is to do that
on episode 2 on the same day episode 2
is out on the same day but just right
after
yeah yeah and then all the episodes on
the website will have live chat on their
first viewing
will they right that's that's been the
idea and tomorrow the day before this
all goes down we are gonna make a final
decision on that and by the time right
you're hearing this the decision will
have been made so let us know in the
comments below if we actually did what
we were hoping to do because yeah
there's definitely a bit of a technology
thing to figure out in the process so
yeah
yeah I mean I love it if we can pull it
off I really love the idea I I like the
idea I there's some restrictions and
some limitations and some things we got
to talk about tomorrow but part of the
part of the best part about this is that
every season every episode we're getting
better you know and uh
thank God we might not you could spend
10 years trying to do one thing
perfectly and it would never happen
because you spent every you nitpicked
every little thing about it
thing is we got a great show it's coming
out and uh
it's gonna be great so that's all I know
yeah it's a special show yeah it's an
amazingly entertaining there's nothing
else like it
so it really is I mean let's be real if
you're listening to this podcast
you're gonna like it you should go check
it out you are yeah if you're a true Ton
you're here with us chilling in the
corridor cast you're gonna like son of a
dungeon we cut out all the things that
are boring about DND I mean that's
really it and kept all the fun things
yeah here's how it works
out there keep the good stuff and you
throw some sick VFX shots and sick on
real engine renders to illustrate it
yep there you go there you go
yeah there you go just takes about 10
months to do that but we did it takes a
while yeah I mean it takes a little time
my hope for season three is that v1s are
closer to V2s and v3s of this season's
assuming the same team all right Mr
editories you're still in it in your
brain you're thinking you're you're
seeing the tracks right now
all right look over this Horizon I can
see a whole town could build right here
take us out
v3s will be your V ones in season three
those v3s
are gonna be a breeze
that's right you've got it
thanks for watching everybody we will
see you next time oh oh oh last thing oh
check out the season finale of crew cuts
if you haven't okay bye okay yeah that
was a blast